oui on est en live
il faut deviner le poids de john rachid
mais bon on attend un peu comme la
balance vers 70 à 55 22 à 95 et 1 voix
avec plein de micro et tout ira bien
c'est une balance qui déconne il ya une
bonne réponse sur twitter mais peut-être
que forget orient à la bonne réponse 90
attention je suis pas aussi gros que ça
calme toi qu'est-ce qu'il a reperdu
c'est mon année de naissance à quatre
policiers ou bien tu choisis j'avais des
téléphones moubarak beaucoup nous
manquer a vu c'est une boutique aux
écoles vas tu es tu as gagné une sorte
de tablette de gaming à la place des
quotas avec des quittances du ruban
voilà j'ai l'impression d'être animateur
fiscale quand on roule c'est génial de
faire le quiz vrai faux norman a arrêté
les cours en quatrième vrai ou faux faux
faux faux comme toi c'est faux ces fonds
par contre - oui norman est ambidextre
c'est à dire qu'il peut écrire de la
main droite et de la main gauche vrai ou
faux c'est vrai c'est vrai voilà alors
c'est complètement faux tu as perdu
ge energy à son passeport français vrai
ou faux vrai il ne l'a pas vu du niveau
va voir madeira vidéo sur cuba jeune et
je le dis que je vais pas me passer par
france est vrai ou faux mister v a
grandi dans les quartiers chauds de
grenoble s'est pas totalement rendus
dans une résidence eu beau tout seul et
noir et noir vrai ou faux vrai ou faux
mais on dirait qu'ils croient un peu il
préparait un boubou ce problème lucien
est ce que norman est aussi un nom de
sapins oui oui oui bon dans john rachid
il y à une faute d'orthographe pas fait
exprès lors de sa création
vrai il a gagné ça tient bien gagner mon
gars on a un cadeau à offrir c'est
celui-là way juste une devenu si c'est
un livre c'est cool j'aime bien les
livres c'est un livre c'est à dire ça
j'adore les livres j'adore les hôtels et
une ps4 et dégoûté mais il faut donner
des années est fait par quelqu'un de
connu et de sortie a très peu de temps
capitable livre sans google si roger et
c'est humain
oui excellent de vivre sera également
dédicacé par cyprien et vous pouvez le
dédicacer vous deux sont des cas sociaux
non mais parfait ont lieu ont fait des
dégâts c'est aussi par le maître de la
lumière du soleil mais c'est le jeu de
la faune c'est le jeu de la punchline
mais parlons de manger est superbe
je crois que j'ai foutu on veut pourquoi
parce qu'ils se retrouvent plus ah si
c'est bon il ya mon gentil a dit suis-je
métrosexuels sigean un contrôleur
chercheur belle mais un récital avec
deux miches maladroite de l'énorme
stress être gay co2 place
excellent comme il habite à montpellier
ce que tu viens son pari mais pas
longtemps
pas vraiment pas grave tu déplaces le
placement paris joue bientôt à push
croise pas à montpellier dans halloween
lui l'enjoindre à purger je suis jaloux
je joue à strasbourg pas bon à
montpellier ça t'arrange ou pas le
monologue engine la médecine est une
[ __ ] le maquereau c'est son pharmacien
il s'appelait des rappeurs comme pas du
tout des rappeurs moi je fais 84 kg ce
soir j'en ai plus rien à péter j'ai le
droit de chercher bien longtemps le
droit d'enlever l'histoire en étant le
droit de chercher ses pronos rome
bouclée
tu as gagné à porto a gagné wimbledon
excellent ils sont mais qui hélas oui
oui
on a noté du livre est-ce que tu ne
signerait pas en direct pour chloé ce
livre va aller chez toi très vite avec
la dédicace des jaunes il a jeu avec
marc talonnade à la madjer burqa c'est
un quinqua en direct via des mignonnes
tu me fais un bisou mais n'appelle pas
du doigt
je suis pas ton tautou paz le suçon dans
le cou sinon je t'insulte d'autres tout
je dirais jul pour investir un petit
cadeau c'est un petit poucet smiley c
est ce qu on ferait pas le quiz des
parents les internautes à huy pose des
questions aux parents les plus cocasses
une fois quelqu'un de plus âgé avait
quelque chose
ce chien est très concentré mais surtout
très à l'aise pourquoi parce qu'il a
chez sandrine qui est votre humoriste
préférée je me gare soit la [ __ ]
plasma la cendrillon je vous dis non à
tout ça vous évoque quoi à une marque de
confiserie de la lingerie un peu
fréquent même où une humoriste maintenir
les réponses 3 c'est une bonne réponse
n'a pas le temps d'être sandrine vous
habitez charte charte à côté à côté de
pau merci à gagner deux places de
spectacles dans la tour c'est le queens
deux savoie
acteur connu joue un stormtrooper c'est
un ton père on regarde à quoi ça
ressemble à ça
quels acteurs jouent ceux ci cet acteur
à jouer james bond daniel craig
qu'est-ce que salomé nico tu as gagné
instable laser quoi cela peut-il
désormais la perspective service ya pas
d indices moi je tourne bien c'est un
objet qui ne va pas forcément sur le sol
c'est un animal en anglais exaspère à
faire des vidéos et si tu remplaces la
première lettre par union blanc c'est
indigeste savoldelli technologique non
mais juste ça va ça ne s'éteindront mike
deux matches où il termine une bd ça
prend ça
qu'est ce que l'on trouve là dedans on
peut se mouvoir a marre on peut se
déplacer avec ses ipod high-tech leila
il a eu un flash
toujours bon à l'aller
elle est terminée
où